Donald Trump jr. is expected to appear
today before the Senate Judiciary
Committee in a closed meeting
congressional investigators are looking
into whether the Trump campaign
conspired with the Russian government
during the 2016 election the president's
oldest son has become a key figure in
the investigation he agreed to a June
2016 meeting with a Kremlin linked
lawyer along with Paul Manafort and
Jared Kushner after being promised dirt
on Hillary Clinton Jeff PJ's is on
Capitol Hill with the highly anticipated
appearance Jeff good morning good
morning congressional investigators want
to know what really happened in that
Trump Tower meeting and they also want
to question Donald Trump jr. about his
father's decision to fire former FBI
director James Comey now Donald Trump
jr. will be here on Capitol Hill for
this closed-door meeting on the heels of
Facebook's revelation yesterday that an
internal investigation found a Russian
linked Rolf farm spread 3,000 ads on the
platform as part of a political
influence operation Facebook was paid
about $100,000 for the ads that it
believes was part of a campaign to
spread divisive and polarizing
information on topics like immigration
gun rights race and LGBTQ issues but
didn't seem to back a particular
candidate Facebook has handed that
information over to federal agents
leading the Russia probe and at the
heart of that investigation is whether
the Trump campaign coordinated with
Russian operatives during the 2016
election and if Donald Trump jr. doesn't
cooperate today in the view of Democrats
on Capitol Hill he could face a subpoena
because what the Democrats really want
is for him to testify in public Charlie
Jeff thanks